à la tour l'adresse huppé de new york le
personnel devine les moindres désirs des
résidents bonjour mais c'est chaud tout
est prêt pour votre réception
franchement je ne sais pas ce que je
ferais sans vous mais ça ils ne
l'auraient jamais deviné il ya tout
juste une heure le plus riche occupants
de laxou drogue est relaxé merci mis à
domicile il ya quelques années il lui a
été demandé de gérer votre épargne à
tous aujourd'hui ils disent que tous
ceux qui ont investi auprès de monsieur
show se sont fait escroquer il a eu
votre argent oui il l'a eu si vous avez
besoin de moi j'habite dans mon carton
on n'a toujours pas trouvé le filet de
sécurité de show 20 millions de dollars
et quelque donc tu as l'intention de
voler arthur chaud chez lui dans un
bâtiment des agents du fbi avaient
surveillé 24 heures sur 24 on est pas
des criminels dont les cas sont n'y
connais rien c'est bon je connais un
expert t'inquiète
besoin d'un chauffeur pourquoi tu as
payé ma caution je suis pas comment tu
t'appelles nous déposer toi et moi tous
les matins chez la nounou mais monsieur
syncope l'optique arrêtait pas de faire
des cinq ans qu une personne voulait
faire la sieste avec toi ni faire de
coloriage n'est rien juste sur un plan c
koi tu essaies de 40 et 20 millions de
dollars on déjeune ensemble
et les bonnets des cagoules que j'ai
demandé et g indiqué n'ai rien touché le
fond à quoi ça sert abonnés on doit
avoir le visage couvert il n'a jamais
été question d'un vrai qu au franc fort
l'acier du c'est qu'on vise 20 millions
$ tu voyais un coffre en bois vous
n'êtes que de petits employés vite
remplacé peu importe ce que je devrais
faire je trouverai le moyen de rectifier
le tir
la femme de chambre est cinglé
d'abord on cherche ou tenter un passage
on se sert de ses doigts quand on a
trouvé le passage